it's a viral video going around right
now you've probably seen it Cubs game
there's a Cubs game and there was a foul
ball and a guy catches it while holding
his baby yeah this thing is very popular
it has already gotten 2 million views if
you didn't see it check it out for the
right side and Adrian Gonzalez leans in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's incredible to me he's not just told
the baby he's feeding the baby the
entire time and he catches the ball yeah
alright well that got me thinking isn't
it kind of strange that some videos go
viral others sort of go nowhere nobody
checks him out now that foul ball video
broke on the same day as another
incredible video that no one is talking
about this other video took place during
one of the games of the NBA Finals
a mother who was feeding her baby twins
was chosen for the halftime challenge
yeah and here's what happened
[Applause]
[Applause]
News
[Applause]
23 hues for that I just don't get it
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography